>> Kenny: UNDER WAY IN ST. PAUL
THEIR GOALTENDERS AND THEY THINK
THEY CAN TURN THIS WILD
HAULA WINS IT.
DUMBA UNABLE TO CLEAR THE PUCK
AHEAD.
.
McAVOY'S SHOT STEERED ASIDE BY!
THE SCREEN.
>> E
WILD.
S SECOND OF THE GAME AN OUTSTAN.
THERE'S THE 75th.
SHOT BY CARLO, BLOCKED B B DETEE
PROBABILITY OF
THE BRUINS TIE THE GNT.
IT DOESN'T.
JUST GETS BY HIM.
NO BRUIN IN FRY THERE.
LOOK AT THE GOALTENDER JUST DID
NOT PICK IT UP AND ENDS UP IN
THE BACK OF THE NET.N
BRUIN COME TUESDAY OR MONDAY
EVENING AFTER THE TRADE
DEADLINE.
>> Eddie: JUST NEEDS TO GAIN
SOME EXPERIENCE ANTHE BRUINS FO.
GOOD STICK BY FORBOR.
PUCK SENT ALONG
OPPOSITION.
>> Eddie: JONESY, THAT'SOFTEN I.
>> Eddie: CHILI'S IS.
>> Eddie: COMES OFF A NINE SHOT
GAME LAST NIGHT IN THAT OVERTIME
.
>> Kenny: HE HAS BEEN ALL OVER.
>> Eddie: HE REALLY SWAYMAN.
WILD WERE GOING TO TAKE THE LEAD
IN THI!
HEADS-UP PLAY
BY SPURGEON GETTING THE PUCK
THROUGH TO THE NET.
IT WAS TIPPED BY.
>> Kenny: ALL SMILES ON THE
BENCH FROM JORDAN GREENWAY.
>> Kenny: OUT TO THE POINT ANDY.
SEASON FOR RYAN HARTMAN HAVING A